et sans doute fils à qui il a dit ça
c'était au moment de la grande bulle
internet première bulle avant que son
explosion et l'exubérance des marchés eu
effectivement la formule et beaucoup de
succès et banque centrale les banques
centrales sont un instrument extrêmement
puissant et audacieux mènent elles
peuvent faillir réussir mais ya là un
instrument brigue parce qu'au bout du
compte c'est le le prêteur en dernier
ressort
et comme si le prêteur en dernier
ressort l'utilisation par exemple qu'au
travers de la crise les états unis ont
fait de la fed sous la houlette de
berlin qui est à mon avis assez
exemplaire au problème
ils ont maintenant la fel un bilan
extrêmement gonflé comment est ce qu'ils
vont faire maigrir le bilan ça c'est
très compliqué mais l'instrument a été
utilisé pour éviter les ennuis
le problème pour nous c'est qu'en dépit
des qualités éminentes de mario draghi
et les efforts considérables qu'il a
fait pour que le système européen
tiennent debout la bce n'est pas un
prêteur en dernier ressort
ça n'est qu'un ersatz de banque centrale
car ça n'est pas une banque centrale qui
est appuyée sur un état une banque
centrale qui a un capital banque
centrale elle est centrale
36 raisons techniques et notamment parce
qu'elle l'aimait la monnaie centrale qui
sert de règlement aux banques entre
elles mais elle est aussi central parce
que lé prêteur en dernier ressort et que
l'état est derrière c'est pas le cas de
la bce et donc la situation de la bce et
qui sont très particulières qui fait
qu'elles jouent sur les marchés comme
une banque centrale
mais avec nice ferment d'instabilité qui
qui pourraient un jour se révéler
dangereux donc sur la question générale
que vous posiez le rôle des banques
centrales tout à fait considérable et je
considère pour ma part que dans la crise
depuis 2007 2008 elles ont bien joué
leur rôle bien fonctionné et que l on
sauver la mise
plusieurs reprises avec un inconvénient
qui est que par définition
l'intervention de la banque centrale
d'un seul court terme
or les gouvernements je n'en cite aucun
en particulier mais notamment aux
gouvernements européens ont eu tendance
c'est l'effet piégeant les déclarations
de mario draghi sur llorente c'est que
va puisque la banque centrale résout le
problème on n'a pas à faire les réformes
qu'il faut la banque centrale va y
pallier sauf que notre âne de pallier
aux problèmes que la court terme et donc
en salle et gouvernement s'exonère des
actions de long terme qu'ils doivent
conduire se reposant sur la banque
centrale alors que la banque centrale
devrait traiter que les problèmes de
court terme et donc on a là un effet
pervers de la puissance même de la
banque centrale qui peut à elle seule
stabiliser le marché
mais avec un effet pervers qui cueillis
c'est très bien à condition que ça
n'empêche pas de faire ce qui est offert
par ailleurs aujourd'hui en europe
ça empêche le ministre il y a deux ou
trois petites questions techniques que
nous n'avons pas pu aborder je vous
engage à nous y répondre par écrit si
vous le souhaitez par ailleurs nous vous
ferons parvenir le compte rendu de cette
audition je rappelle que notre
commission denquête qui est
mathématiquement la représentation de
l'ensemble des groupes du sénat s'était
unanimement entendre l'ancien directeur
du fmi
c'est fait vous avez attendu à nos
questions l'audition est terminé merci
voilà pour l'audition de dominique
strauss kahn l'ancien directeur du fmi
qui a donc été entendu hier après-midi
par la commission d' enquête sénatoriale
sur le rôle des banques dans l'évasion
fiscale on va rester dans le même sujet
car depuis ce matin à les sénateurs
examinent en seconde lecture le projet
de loi de régulation et de séparation
des activités bancaires
alors sans plus tarder direction
l'hémicycle bonne séance à tous monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues nous
allons reprendre nos travaux le tuilage
se fait dans de bonnes conditions et je
suis saisie de cinq amendements
identiques faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune donc le de rectifier
wismes chevalier merci madame la
présidente je laisse mes chers collègues
je n'ai plus la moment sous les yeux
mais cela ne fait rien je vais le faire
de tête
il s'agit effectivement de revenir sur
un débat que nous avions eues en
première lecture puisque cet amendement
vise à permettre la possibilité pour un
emprunteur de rené roux de renégocier le
contrat d'assurance attachées aux prêts
annuellement alors lors du débat en
première lecture nous avait expliqué que
ça n'était pas possible de le faire que
les contrats proposés par les banques
étaient les contrats de groupe etc et
donc il y avait une sorte de
mutualisation du coup et que si l'on
permettait effectivement à l'emprunteur
de renégocier le contrat tous les ans on
mettrait en déséquilibre l'ensemble je
me permets de répondre tout de suite par
avance à cet argument en disant qu' il
me semble assez assez mal fondées
puisque lorsqu'un emprunteur souhaitent
souscrire un contrat assurantielle
questionnaire de santé et on sait bien
que pour ceux qui ont la malchance
d'avoir quelques soucis de santé le taux
qui l'aurait proposé est un taux bien
plus défavorable pour que ceux qui n'en
ont pas et il en va de même en fonction
de l'âge du souscripteur est donc je ne
vois pas pourquoi nous ne permettrions
pas effectivement de faire jouer la
concurrence à plein donc au moment de au
moment où le prêt souscrit et ensuite
chaque année avec la possibilité pour
l'emprunteur de dénoncer le contrat à
partir du moment bien évidemment où il
amène un contrat couvrant les mêmes
risques
merci monsieur d'allier la maman 6
rectifié man lienemann n'est pas défendu
ils t'en mets l'identique
je ne doute pas que monsieur foucault le
défend même avis je vous remercie
monsieur colin même avis je remercie
monsieur gâteau là
oui merci mais madame la présidente
d'entrer rapidement
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
cet amendement qui est identique au
précédent vise à permettre un emprunteur
de résilier son assurance dès lors qu'il
apporte la preuve qu'il souscrive une
danse dans le même temps à une autre
assurance du même niveau de garantie en
effet les assurances représente pour
l'emprunteur environ 25% du coût du
crédit génère par ailleurs démarche
extrêmement élevé pour les banques
il semblerait donc a priori logique
d'appliquer à l'assurance emprunteur
cette mesure déjà prévue dans le projet
de loi de la consommation en ce qui
concerne d assurance automobile et
habitation
si monsieur gâteau là je vais donc
demander l'avis de la commission sur ces
quatre amendements identiques
monsieur le rapporteur merci madame la
présidente
l'objet de ces amendements qui est
identique a été exposé notre commission
les a examinés et demandent ce que
j'appellerais un retrait provisoire
c'est une variété nouvelle ce que
foucault ça change
non mais c'est pour paraître toujours
entière voire négatif je réponds à
monsieur d'allier sur le problème de
de la prime les du risque ce que vous
dites est bien sûr exact il y à un
questionnaire à remplir et que
évidemment si on a 68 ans une maladie
incurable et un certain nombre d'autres
m'ont on paye on paye plus cher
ceci étant ceci ne veut pas dire que
tout le monde paye proportionnellement à
haut risque qu'il représente il y à une
péréquation
je dirais général entre par exemple les
jeunes générations et ceux qui sont plus
âgés
il ya un équilibre qui se fait
évidemment sinon ceux qui ont 20 ans qui
sont en pleine santé père est
sensiblement moins que ceux qui sont qui
sont plus âgés or c'est le principe même
de l'assurance et qu'il y à une
mutualisation du risque et par
conséquent notre sentiment c'est que les
amendements pourraient comporter le
risque de mettre en cause les primes des
assurés en tout cas les plus les plus
fragiles les plus modestes
j'ajoute que le gouvernement qui est
sensible à l'argument mais il exprimera
bien sûr a demandé un rapport qui étudie
l'ensemble des aspects de cette question
et ce rapport doit être remis je crois
d'ici la fin de l'année au gouvernement
donc il nous a semblé qu'il était
probable en plus plus sage plus
raisonnable d'attendre là la
connaissance et la publication de ce
rapport avant de se prononcer sur
l'amendement que vous les amendements
que vous suggérez pas conséquent demande
de retrait si monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le ministre votre avis pour le
gouvernement
oui mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
nous sommes exactement sur la même
position que celle du rapporteur il y à
une nécessité d'approfondir les études
d'impact de bien mesurer les
conséquences de ces propositions il a
été prévu qu'un rapport
où l'avez rappelé monsieur le rapporteur
serait élaboré à cette fin donc dans la
tente de l'élaboration de ce rapport
nous demandons plats aussi le retrait
temporaire
merci monsieur le ministre donc j'ai
demandé à monsieur d'allier ce qu'ils
pensent des demandes de retrait
proviseur provisoire et temporaire on ne
sait pas très bien où tout cela nous
emmène moi je souhaiterais puis on verra
ce que la cmp fait derrière je
souhaiterais que le sénat marque sa
volonté de voir adopté cette disposition
si nous allions scrutin public je crois
qu'effectivement cet amendement serait
adoptée on va peut-être pas aller jusque
là mais je pense qu'il ya un consensus
sur ces bancs pour marquer l'intention
du sénat donc je ne retire pas cet
amendement et je souhaite que nous
adoptions
merci monsieur alliés mais c'est le
ministre pour rassurer monsieur sénateur
je veux lui confirmer qu'il ya une
possibilité de procéder au réexamen de
cette question à l'occasion de la
deuxième lecture du projet de loi sur la
consommation donc ce n'est pas une
demande de retrait avec aucune clause de
revoyure c'est une demande de retrait de
manière à ce que le rapport puisse être
élaborée porté à la connaissance du
parlement et qu'à ce moment là la
question puisse être retraité à
l'occasion de la deuxième lecture du
projet de loi sur la consommation
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur café
merci madame la présidente très
rapidement c'est un sujet dont nous
avons beaucoup débattu en première
lecture qui a été également débattu à
l'envi
à l'assemblée nationale et c'est un
sujet qui est extrêmement difficile sur
lequel je crois véritablement qu' il ne
faut surtout pas légiférer à l'aveuglent
j'avais indiqués en première lecture que
il y avait tout d'abord des problèmes
d'ordre juridique sur cette question je
constate par exemple que les amendements
ne disent pas si la mesure est
rétroactive ou pas est-ce qu'elle
s'applique aux contrats en cours ou pas
si elle s'applique aux contrats en cours
je crains qu'il n'y ait un problème
constitutionnel qui à mon avis devrait
être un peu expertise et selon le
principe de non rétroactivité des lois
en matière contractuelle
il ya d'autres problèmes juridiques
également ce donc rien que sur cette
sphère juridique je crois qu'il faut
être extrêmement prudent et examiner
cette question mais peut-être que la
question juridique n'a pas de la plus
importante
il ya la question en fait où nous
risquons de légiférer en poursuivant un
objectif qui ne sera pas atteint et
peut-être que nous atteindrons
l'objectif inverse
je m'explique d'ailleurs il faudrait
savoir quel est l'objectif qui est
poursuivi est ce qu'il s'agit de réduire
les marges des banques comme je les ai
souvent entendu dire en première lecture
franchement si c'est ça il ya peut-être
d'autres moyens est-ce qu'il s'agit
d'accroître le pouvoir d'achat des
clients des banques qui souscrivent une
assurance accroissement du pouvoir
d'achat lié à la concurrence et c'est là
véritablement que nous avons un débat à
voir mais approfondi sur la base d'un
rapport des mois je me félicite que le
gouvernement en fait et commandé ce
rapport pourquoi parce que l'assurance
privée fonctionne de manière
fondamentalement différente que
l'assurance collective est le contraire
de groupe
voilà le contrat de groupe se
caractérise et je crois qu'il ya
beaucoup d'études qui le montre par une
couverture large et une segmentation
tarifaire réduite
pourquoi tout simplement grâce à la
mutualisation comme l'a indiqué le
rapporteur
l'assurance privée individuelle se fonde
par une couverture qui est lié au risque
et ce qui risque de se passer
en fait c'est que un certain nombre s'il
voulait de risque qui sont mutualisées
dans le contrat de groupe
si nous disons aux bas le contrat de
groupe maintenant je dis pas que ça ne
n'existe plus mais doit être substituée
à une assurance privée
nous risquons avoir le résultat
exactement inverse que celui que nous
recherchons c'est à dire que à ce moment
là la segmentation tarifaire étant
beaucoup plus élevé dans l'assurance
privée
nous risquons en fait de défavorisés
ceux qui le sont déjà et un certain
nombre de populations fragiles donc je
crois qu'il faut manier cette cette
discussion et cette décision surtout
avec beaucoup de précaution faisons
attention aux conséquences que un tel
dispositif s'il était adopté par le
parlement pourrait avoir bon et c'est la
raison pour laquelle moi je crois qu'il
serait sage en fait de différer la
décision que nous devons prendre qu elle
soit éclairé par un rapport bon
indiquant véritablement quels sont les
avantages respectifs du contrat de
groupe et de l'assurance collective avec
la mutualisation et ce en fait du
recours à l'assurance privée et donc moi
si le gouvernement me dit mais il y a un
filet de sécurité
il y a la possibilité de légiférer en
pleine connaissance de cause lors de la
deuxième lecture du projet de loi qui
est porté par benoît hamon je crois que
nous saurions sage ce soir a retiré ses
amendements et à examiner véritablement
les conclusions du rapport qui nous a
soumis
si monsieur café messieurs foucault oui
moi je suis excusé moi je suis de l'avis
de monsieur d'allier puis
je dirais mais ce café faut pas couper
les cheveux en quatre il faut rester
dans une certaine logique
on peut à la fois voter pour marquer
l'intérêt du sénat sur cette question ce
soir et pour ensuite revenir sur la loi
sur sur la consommation
simplement dire qu'il ya quand même déjà
des études qui sont disponibles qui
montrent qu'on ne peut rétablir
raisonnablement imaginer déstabiliser un
marché qui je crois dégage 50%
c'est encore % monsieur café de marges
de distribution
donc à partir de là c'est encore une
question je dirais de de morale et il ya
aussi le regard sur nous et puis il ya
aussi notre éthique nous et ce que l'on
veut faire et puis je crois
qu'aujourd'hui pouvoir d'achat est assez
rare il s'agit aussi de redonner un peu
de pouvoir d'achat aux gens par la
mesure que l'on entend prendre avec cet
amendement qui vient d'être déposé c'est
pourquoi moi je le maintiens et
messieurs présents foucault monsieur
colin vous êtes aussi sollicité pour un
retrait oui madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
même s'il ya un certain consensus sur
ces amendements je crois qu'il faut
savoir parfois faire preuve de patience
et peut-être même de sagesse bien écouté
les arguments de notre collègue café les
arguments également et la proposition de
monsieur le ministre nous nous rangerons
à saint-avit de sagesse nous retirerons
cet amendement merci chers collègues ce
gâteau la donc vous avez aussi été
sollicités si madame la présidente oui
écoutez j'ai entendu l'engagement du
ministre de réétudier la question dans
le cadre de la deuxième lecture de la
loi consommation
fort de cet engagement et de la
compréhension de la complexité du sujet
et du rapport qui sera remis
je retire la membre monsieur gattolin
donc s'il n'y a pas de demande
d'explications de vote je vais mettre
aux voix donc les deux amendements qui
n'ont pas été retirés
celui de chevalier le dû rectifier bis
lé puis celui de monsieur fukui 18 ils
sont identiques qui votent ces deux
amendements identiques du bourg
merci contre merci ils ne sont pas
adoptées nous passons un amendement 47
rectifier mais c'est présent foucault et
fendue madame la présidente
il tirait les conclusions des
amendements que nous avons discuté à
l'instant pourra y aller un peu plus
loin je dirais simplement que je ne le
défends parce que je sais que le
rapporteur a demandé de le retirer ou
émettre un avis des fans mais si mais si
mais il faut court messieurs le reporter
c'est bien ça c'est l'amendement de
conséquences oui merci madame la
présidente
foucault deviner en fait pour les mêmes
raisons que le débat que nous venons
d'avoir par conséquent notre commission
qui a regardé votre votre proposition je
développe pas les arguments mais je
reprend l'idée de du rapport qui doit
être soumis et donc c'est une demandera
une demande de retrait le magazine
féministe même avis bien vous voulez
retirer monsieur foucault non monsieur
fukui a voulu retirer merci de nous en
sommes nous en sommes arrivés à au vote
sur l'article 18 qui est pour voter
l'article 18
merci qui est contre abstention il est
adopté même vote pour l'article 18 bis
chers collègues pas d'opposition même
vote
l'article 20 même vote pas d'opposition
l'article 21 même vote
merci nous arrivons l'article 22 le
moment 50 qui présentait donc par
monsieur au nom de la commission
c'est un amendement coordination madame
la présidente très bien monsieur le
ministre
favorable je vais mettre aux voix
l'amendement de coordination qui a reçu
un avis favorable du gouvernement qui
est pour le voter merci contre
abstentions il est adopté
nous arrivons votre sur l'article 22
qui est pour voter l'article 22 merci
contre abstentions il est adopté sur
l'article 22 quater je ne suis saisi
d'aucun amendements et d'aucune demande
de parole je me vois cet article je me
vois cet article voilà très bien
oui alors sur le 23 alors même votre
sueur sur le 23 mai motte sur le 23
verges et une demande de parole de
monsieur le président suaire à mme la
présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues je voulais souligner
devant vous la grande importance de cet
article 23 ter et remercié
chaleureusement eu nos collègues eux
mohamed swahili et young richard yung
qui ont bien voulu défendre l'amendement
qui a permis de créer cet article 23 ter
de quoi s'agit-il
il s'agit que des contrats obsèques
vous savez qu'à la faveur de la lecture
précédente vous avez bien voulu adopter
déjà des dispositions de manière à ce
que l'on ne confonde pas les contrats
obsèques à d'autres contrats peu qu'ils
n'ont rien à voir
un contrat obsèques est un contrat qui
doit se référer à une description
personnalisé des obsèques dans des
conditions qui sont strictement prévues
par la loi et qui bien souvent ne sont
pas appliquées mais le contenu de cet
article 23 est très important pour les
millions de personnes qui ont souscrit
des contrats obsèques
c'est dire que c'est loin d'être anodin
en effet jusqu'à aujourd'hui les sommes
qui sont versées au titre des contrats
obsèques ne sont nullement revalorisé
c'est à dire que les compagnies qui
perçoivent ces sommes qui les gardent
les places et les souscripteurs ne
bénéficient en rien d'une revalorisation
des contrats obsèques
c'est ce qui a conduit et j'insiste
là-dessus madame la présidente à la fois
le sénat puis l'assemblée nationale a
adopté à l'unanimité dans les deux
assemblées
un article dans la loi de décembre 2008
relative au droit funéraire qui
instaurer la revalorisation de ces
contrats au taux légal
nous pensions que une fois cet article
voté tout simplement la loi
s'appliquerait or cet article voté en
2008 ne s'applique toujours pas pourquoi
parce que les compagnies d'assurance ont
fait valoir qu'il existait une directive
européenne du 5 novembre 2002 concernant
n'ont pas les contrats obsèques mais
l'assurance vie et ils ont eux plaidé
que cette directive s'appliquer aux
contrats obsèques et ce dernier texte
européen impose aux contrats d'assurance
vie le respect de certaines règles
prudentielles et interdit à la survie de
prendre des engagements qu'ils ne
pourraient pas respecter
alors nous avons pris contact avec les
services au service monsieur le ministre
il y à déjà quatre ans et nous avons eu
de nombreuses réunions et cela a duré
des mois et des mois et finalement nous
avons tous pu trouver un accord sur la
formulation de la revalorisation
je ne voulais pas tout le texte madame
la présidente monsieur le ministre
sachez seulement que d'accord a été
conclu sur les termes suivants avec le
ministre avec le ministère avec vos
services
monsieur le ministre cazeneuve eux ils
lui affecté chaque année lorsqu'il est
positif un montant correspondant à une
quote-part du solde créditeur du compte
financier au moins égal à 80 5% de ce
solde x le rapport entre les provisions
mathématiques relatives à ce contrat et
le total des provisions mathématiques
diminué d intérêt
dit et aux provisions mathématiques
relative à ce même contrat au cours de
l'exercice
je pense que tout le monde a suivi
notamment monsieur françois marque qui
rapporteur général du budget toujours
est il que cela a un aspect un peu
complexe en effet mais se traduira pour
l'ensemble des souscripteurs d'un
contrat obsèques par une revalorisation
qui ne sera pas exactement aux taux
d'intérêt légal mais de l'ordre des
trois quarts de ce taux donc pour
beaucoup de souscripteurs et de famille
ce sera important
alors cet amendement je dois remercier
tout le monde avait déjà été présenté
par madame nicole bonnefoy dans le cadre
du projet de loi de monsieur lefebvre
mais ce projet n'a pas prospéré c'est
dire que nous remercions et je remercie
parce que la commission des lois s'était
beaucoup impliqué là dessus la
commission des finances et son
rapporteur richard yung suite au
plaidoyer de thani mohamed soilihi
d'avoir repris cela est vrai chez
recoller je voulais tout simplement vous
inviter à voter cet article si j'ai pris
quelques minutes de votre temps de notre
temps c'est parce que cela n'est pas
anodin et se traduira très concrètement
pour des millions de souscripteurs des
contrats obsèques dont je vous remercie
de bien vouloir adopter cet article 23
heures merci monsieur le président ce
faire alors si tous mes collègues ont
compris ont bien compris l'équation
je vais mettre aux voix l'article 23 ter
qui est pour
merci qui est contre l'abstention
monsieur sur mesure prise en sueur
article est votée je mets ou voit le 23
quater qui est pour
merci contre abstentions il est adopté
même vote pour le 24 bis mes chers
collègues même vote
merci
même votre pour l'article 30 même votre
merci à l'article 31
il ya un amendement 26 mai qui n'est pas
défendu ils tombent et je mets aux voix
l'article 31 bis et pour merci contre
abstentions il est adopté
même votre pour eux l'article 33 même
voir quelle dernière un pic la beauté
même vote il est adopté
mes chers collègues féministes les
autres dispositions du projet de loi ne
font pas l'objet de la deuxième lecture
je vais donc mettre aux voix l'ensemble
du projet de loi y at-il de demandes
d'explications de vote
oui monsieur cola music hall à vous avez
la parole merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
notre groupe maintiendra son vote de
première lecture sur ce projet de loi de
séparation et de régulation des
activités bancaires
en effet comme l'a souligné mon collègue
françois fortassin lors de la discussion
générale les principaux articles du
projet de loi ayant été adopté conforme
à l'assemblée nationale le coeur du
texte reste inchangé et va donc de même
il va de même pour notre vote
il est vrai que nous aurions souhaité
une séparation des activités
monsieur le ministre un peu plus
ambitieuse c'était l'objet de nos
amendements portant sur la tenue de
marché en première lecture
et c'est également la raison pour
laquelle de nos collègues ont choisi de
s'abstenir sur l'ensemble de ce projet
de loi comme tous les autres membres du
rdse lui apportent leur soutien
nous voulons croire que malgré quelques
faiblesses ce texte n'en constitue pas
moins un tournant majeur en matière de
régulation financière des conséquences
dévastatrices de la crise qui a éclaté
aux états unis il y à déjà 5 ans nous
impose de prendre des mesures fortes en
matière de transparence de lutte contre
la fraude d'optimisation fiscale
d'encadrement des rémunérations dans le
secteur financier ou encore de
prévention et de résolution des crises
bancaires
c'est ce que fait ce projet de loi même
si nous aurions souhaité sur cette
certains points que la france prenne de
l'avancé soit une source d'inspiration
pour ses partenaires européens
comme elle l'a déjà été d'ailleurs avec
la taxe sur les transactions financières
plutôt que d'attendre une prise de
décision collective à bruxelles pour
l'entrée en application de certaines
dispositions
en revanche je me réjouis d
enrichissement du texte au cours de la
navette parlementaire en ce qui concerne
la lutte contre les paradis fiscaux et
celle contre la spéculation sur les
matières premières agricoles
notre groupe a lui-même d'ailleurs
contribué à enrichir le texte sur ces
sujets en première lecture
nous aurions voulu aussi aller plus loin
aujourd'hui notamment en ce qui concerne
la clope et l'application des
obligations de transparence pour les
grandes entreprises et nous regrettons
que notre notre amendement ce sujet
n'ait pas été adoptée
je remercie monsieur le ministre la
ministre en l'occurrence monsieur le
ministre lui transmettra qui nous a
rassurés dans son avis sur leur de nos
amendements
quant à l'effectivité de l'application
de l'interdiction faite aux banques de
détenir des stocks physiques de matières
premières agricoles à des fins
spéculatives et je resterai pour ma part
très vigilant sur ce point car la lutte
contre la spéculation sur les matières
premières agricoles est un sujet
stratégique de toute première importance
si nous trouvons quelque peu surprenant
que seule une poignée d'amendements été
adoptée aujourd'hui donc un de
l'opposition avait le soutien des
écologistes sur les 50 déposé en
deuxième lecture cela n'empêchera pas
les membres du rdse d'apporter leur
soutien avec force et conviction à ce
texte
car pour les radicaux de gauche et la
majorité du groupe il s'agit bien
d'entamer la mise au pas de la finance
pour éviter que ne se reproduisent les
dérives de ces dernières années dérives
qui ont conduit à la situation
dramatique que nous connaissons je vous
remercie de votre attention
merci chers collègues merci madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues positions assez proches
de mes collègues du rdse les écolos
riches et des écologistes auraient rêvé
d'une d'une loi plus ambitieuse encore
pour lutter contre la spéculation
ça nous avons des rêves important et je
ne suis pas sûr qu'en l'état et même si
on avait une loi beaucoup plus
ambitieuse
on effaçait tout risque de crise qu'elle
soit systémique ou financière j'ai bien
peur que de toute façon les ce genre
d'incident gravissime de la finance
arrive toujours là où on ne l'attend pas
en tous les cas nous sommes quand même
très satisfait des acquis qui sont là
nous sommes satisfaits du fait que le
gouvernement ait voulu par une réforme
rapide agir vite et agir au mieux et je
dois le dire dans un état de travail
parlementaire et de concertation avec
les deux chambres et avec les différents
groupes
ben je dirais qui honore le travail
parlementaire et de travail que
l'exécutif peut avoir avec son parlement
et ce qui la constitue
donc je vais pas faire un long discours
nourri tirons que nous voterons
naturellement positive de manière
positive à cette loi en cette deuxième
lecture merci merci monsieur gâteau la
gdi la parole à monsieur foucault s'est
pris un faux confort explications de
vote sur le texte
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre est court ce texte avait été
présenté comme une réponse je dirais
d'envergure à la financiarisation
financiarisation je le rappelle délétère
de l'économie et ça c'était dans la
ligne droite ou dans la ligne du
discours du bourget ce projet de loi qui
a été défendu donc par le gouvernement
de notre avis reste très perfectible
je les dis d'entrer dans la discussion
générale si ça ne bougeait pas on aura
un vote défavorable
or sur les amendements que nous avons
présenté aucun nom était retenu si ce
n'est cet amendement que nous avons
obtenue à l'arraché ensemble voilà le
bilan d'une après midi en ce qui
concerne la lutte sur les paradis
fiscaux via leur porte
reportive pays des pays sur les banques
les entreprises à vocation
internationale
rapporteur nous a demandé de retirer les
amendements sur le trait sur le trading
des gosses haute fréquence également sur
la rémunération des dirigeants
d'entreprise sur la syrie de mesures là
encore à la fin comportant mais
concernant la protection notamment des
consommateurs sur les a vus notamment
des banques en matière de frais
assurance emprunteur là dessus le débat
pour nous a été je dirais négatif et en
conséquence de cause nous maintenons
même si ce texte était utile comme je
les dis d'entrée même s'il ya eu des
progrès qui ont été faits mais nous
pensons que c'était possible et il
fallait plus loin pour ces raisons nous
nous abstiendrons merci messieurs faut
commencer d'allier à l'homme le
président du sionisme et chers collègues
je ne sais pas si quelqu'un aura demandé
un scrutin public donc je voulais
simplement préciser les choses le groupe
ump dans son ensemble souhaitez voter
contre nous sommes quelques-uns à nous
abstenir donc j'en fais partie donc je
ne défendrai pas le vote contre du
groupe ump mais à titre personnel je
considère qu effectivement ce texte
contient un certain nombre d'avancées
intéressante voilà pourquoi je
m'abstiendrai et monsieur ministre
permettez moi de vous rappeler
l'engagement que vous avez pris de nous
transmettre un rapport sur cette affaire
des contrats d'assurance liés aux prêts
c'est une affaire importante je ne suis
toujours pas convaincu qu'il y aurait un
déséquilibre donc la deuxième lecture du
texte à venir je ne sais pas quand elle
est fixée
ça vous laisse peut-être un délai pour
nous fournir les informations
nécessaires mais nous les attendons
je ministre chevallier monsieur kassai
merci madame la présidente
mes chers collègues vous ne serez pas
surpris si je me montre un peu plus
enthousiaste que les orateurs précédents
non parce que je crois j'ai la
conviction je crois très profondément
que ce projet de loi restera dans
l'histoire que ce projet de loi en fait
marc une véritable étape en fait dans la
lutte contre la finance quel que soit en
fait les modalités que chacun aurait
peut-être préféré voir engagé et si je
devais caractériser ce projet de loi
j'utiliserai quatre mots le premier
c'est la séparation
le deuxième c'est la résolution le
troisième c'est la moralisation et le
quatrième c'est la protection séparation
oui nous avons séparé les activités
spéculatives des activités
traditionnelles des banques commerciales
d'aucuns auraient préféré que cette
séparation soit beaucoup plus tranchée
est parlé par exemple avec une
séparation totale des entités bancaires
je crois qu'ils ont été une fois ce
route je crois que nous avons
véritablement limiter les opérations
spéculatives nous les avons nous les
avons cantonné et de ce point de vue je
crois que nous avons réussi à faire en
sorte que les banques soient
véritablement utile maintenant à
l'économie réelle
et ceci sans remettre en cause le modèle
de la banque universelle qui je crois
mais peut-être que ce point de vue ne
sera pas complètement partagée a fait
ses preuves
non seulement en france mais en europe
résolution parce que à ceux qui pensent
que la séparation n'est pas allé assez
loin
je dirais que le titre 2 tout ce qui te
concerne en fait la résolution les
pouvoirs qui ont été confiées à la cpr
non seulement dans le contrôle des
banques mais également on a vu
l'occasion d'en discuter
il a quelques minutes sur le contrôle
des nominations
mais le ce titre 2 en fait avec les
pouvoirs qui sont proférées à la cpr et
les modalités de résolution de crise
bancaire et financière et donc y compris
deux faillites est quelque chose qui
n'avait jamais existé dans la
législation française et c'est vraiment
une nouveauté que je considère pour ma
part comme particulièrement importante
le troisième mot que j'ai mentionné tout
à l'heure c'est celui de moralisation
je crois que nous avons franchi des pas
considérables
avec le gouvernement d'ailleurs dans
cette moralisation des activités
financières et ceci sur de très nombreux
aspects que ce soit les paradis fiscaux
que ce soit les rémunérations pas sur
toute une série de sujets nous avons été
je crois et moi j'en tire une certaine
fierté des pionniers ici en france à
l'assemblée et au sénat dans les
discussions en fête qui avait lieu en
europe
et voilà je ne sais pas si c'est une
situation un peu optimiste mais je crois
que nous avons permis en fait à aux
discussions européennes d'aller de
l'avant et peut-être de se dénouer dans
le sens que nous souhaitions et de
manière peut-être plus rapide que nous
l'espérions
et puis il ya le quatrième terme celui
de protection et je pense notamment aux
titres 6 ça avait été la volonté du
gouvernement et du ministre pierre
moscovici nous l'avait annoncé en fait
dès qu'il nous a présenté ce texte ici
il ne concevait pas un texte de loi sur
la régulation et la séparation bancaire
sans penser aux consommateurs et à sa
protection
je crois que nous avons pris en fait
énormément de mesures en la matière en
ce domaine
d'aucuns penseront que voilà nous ne
sommes pas allés assez loin mais rien
que cette mesure qui ne sera pas
symbolique qui ne sera pas symbolique de
man plafonnement des commissions avec
les modalités auquel nous tenons c'est à
dire à la fois un plafond général et un
plafond particulier pour les personnes
les plus défavorisées sera une avancée
quand même me semble-t-il extrêmement
significative
donc voilà ce que je voulais dire c'est
4 terme résume un peu le bilan que nous
tirons nous de cette discussion
je voudrais remercier bien évidemment
notre rapporteur pour la qualité de son
travail et pour aussi la qualité de son
écoute remercié les présidents qui ont
assuré les présidences de séance tant en
première lecture en seconde lecture
et puis remercié le gouvernement et les
ministres qu'ils sont succédé sur ses
bancs parce que rarement me semble-t-il
nous avons eu en fait la possibilité de
mener un travail qui est un véritable
travail de co élaboration d'un texte de
loi sur un sujet particulièrement
difficile est particulièrement important
et où franchement la place des
parlementaires leurs apports respectifs
ont été souvent entendu pas tous
monsieur fukui c'est vrai ont été
entendus et que véritablement nous avons
l'impression que nous avons pu en
quelque sorte qu élaborer ce texte avec
l'exécutif ce qui fait toujours plaisir
à des parlementaires
merci vous ce qu'a fait je n'ai plus de
demandes d'explications de vote sur le
texte
je vais donc mettre aux voix l'ensemble
du projet de loi de séparation et de
régulation des activités bancaires qui
est pour voter ce texte
merci qui est contre
abstention merci le texte est adopté
c'est la fin de cette séance si vous
souhaitez la revoir elle est disponible
en vod sur notre site internet
publicsenat.fr
prochain rendez vous avec les travaux
parlementaires c'est cet après midi à
partir de 15 heures pour la séance de
questions cribles consacrée aujourd'hui
à la situation des caisses d'allocations
familiales très bonne journée à tous